advertisements suck enjoy the show
this podcast has bad words
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is joshua fields milburn ryan
nicodemus is out today he has some sort
of weird thing going on with his eyeball
and i think he was terrified to be on
camera today
but don't worry we actually have three
guests today because today
is a celebration it's our anniversary
cue raphael sadiq with that tony tony
tony
it's our anniversary i've got podcast
sean and jordan no more in the studio
with me
as well but we have three amazing guest
today
really a celebration and a gift for all
of you we got you an
anniversary present it's been 10 years
since we started
the minimalist literally 10 years ago
this week december of 2010
ryan and i started the minimalists.com
it was about
a year and a few months after my mother
died my marriage ended it was a few
months after
ryan had done his packing party and we
had simplified our lives we wanted to
share that story
with everyone else and so for seven
bucks we became the
minimalists.com and we started the blog
and
from there there was this whole
unraveling of the last 10 years and
in fact on the maximal episode this week
over on patreon the minimalists.com
support if you want to check it out
we're going to do a long episode ryan
and i are
together we're going to do a long
episode about the last 10 years we're
going to answer some questions
from the audience over the last 10 years
but we're also
going to really dive into some things
that maybe we haven't even talked about
on the podcast because the podcast is
also
also as an anniversary this month it's
five years old
as well so five years into the
minimalist we'd already put
three books out there we had gone on a
bunch of tours we started a publishing
company
we've been blogging for years but then
we started the podcast we just finished
filming our first film minimalism for
netflix and
actually it was before it was the
netflix thing was even there we just had
finished filming it and we thought
hey let's start a podcast we both really
enjoy listening to podcast so
here we are 10 years later or five years
after the podcast
started and we have some special guests
today ryan and i over the course
of the last seven eight months something
like that we've been doing
these quarantine conversations in fact
we switched them to
quality conversations uh as the
quarantines and the lockdowns began to
lift in different locales and so we've
done 50
different conversations these short
conversations that are anywhere from
10 minutes to 20 25 minutes long
over on our private podcast and what we
wanted to bring you today
were three of those conversations three
of our favorites it's really hard to
pick because
there are so many just great
conversations
and it's been an exercise for me in
listening
to people a lot more and i've really
enjoyed these
short conversations it's almost like
calling a friend and then just recording
it
and putting it on a podcast there's no
definitive format there it's not
necessarily an interview it's a
conversation between two people
and i've been listening to a lot of
different viewpoints over the course
of this year on these conversations
and we've been spelling conversations
with the queue by the way quarantine
conversations or quality conversations
and so we're going to dive into some of
those today
we'll also have an added value segment
and do right here right now at the
end but i thought maybe we could go
ahead and and dive in right now the
first conversation we have
is with glennon doyle now glennon
she wrote a great book this year called
well she released a great book this year
called untamed and it's really a
story about a woman finding herself
and so we got to talk about that what it
means to to find yourself you'll hear
that in the conversation but we'll also
put a link to her new book
untamed in the show notes all right i'll
see you in a few minutes but enjoy this
quality conversation with glennon doyle
well glennon i was hoping to talk to you
about because we were in this
this quarantine i think for for many
people this is maybe
an inciting incident and and they didn't
even realize it i know in
in your new book uh you you you talk
about
um sort of the the starting over finding
your yourself
sort of thing and i'm thinking this
might be this might be the the moment
for a lot of people to
to look inward and somewhat find
themselves
you're right i think you're right
whether we like it or not right
yeah i i mean i i think that you know
sometimes it requires the
the car crash of metaphorically speaking
before we before we course correct
i think so and it's interesting that you
say that because i
have i read a non-profit that that um
helps people who are trying to make ends
meet so i know right now that the
real loss and pain is just staggering
um and then there's this double loss
going on for people which is that
while they're dealing with all this pain
out in the world we are all suddenly
stuck in our homes um
without all the distractions that we
usually
use to keep ourselves from sort of
facing the
truth of being human which is that we
are all
incredibly vulnerable and no one's
really in control and at the end of the
day we really just have each other right
um i think of it in terms of we're kind
of like those snow globes and we keep
ourselves shaken up all the time
so that we don't have to deal with like
the thing in the middle
which is um you know
just the pain and fear and vulnerability
of being human
and right now it feels like we have sort
of a great
settling like a forced settling where
everybody just
is stuck with the pain of being human
um you know the pain in our
relationships all my friends who
you know we're sitting next on the couch
next to our partners now going
all those little cracks that we keep
ourselves busy to distract
ourselves from are just sitting right
there
and it reminds me very much of early
sobriety
for me actually also
well because getting sober is just
distilling of the snow globe
right it's just we use
all of the things like i mentioned
busyness before because that's a more
socially acceptable addiction but
you know i used booze and drugs and food
um
everyone has their things shopping snark
um
scrolling whatever it is and then
recovery comes and it's just
a force settling it's just a you get
you get everything taken away
or you voluntarily um give it away
that keeps you from facing life on its
own terms
right why why do you think that we we
have trouble dealing with that that
discontent and we continue to shake the
the snow globe as you put it
well because i think the truth is in the
stillness right
um everything that we have not healed
um all of the painful emotions
that we know no one ever taught us to
deal with because we live in a culture
that worships happiness
right um the cracks in our relationships
are you know dreams our dreams
that we feel like a braver bolder
version of ourselves would do but we're
not doing them
all of our pain and potential is inside
of stillness and
pain and potential are two things that
are very hard to sit with
right so that's why because it's easier
to um distract ourselves from those
things than to face them but the
beautiful thing is
that anybody who's lucky enough to have
gone through any sort of recovery
program will tell you
and and and why i i see all the real
pain and yet
have great hope for this moment or what
comes
next i should say is that
in my life i have found that every
single good thing
my marriage my health my career my
even my personality all of it
is a result of sitting in that stillness
and feeling all of that pain and digging
into that potential
and um what comes next is usually
something new
and beautiful you talked about finding a
braver bolder self and i like that
i think that sometimes we have a
misconception about what that looks like
we think that a braver version of
ourselves as some sort of
perfect infallible person but it doesn't
sound to me like that's what you're
actually talking about here
yeah i mean i stopped waiting to become
a grown-up a long time ago i figured out
that never happens right we never get to
that
thing that we're all waiting for um i
keep just waking up every day and i just
keep being myself
so that's tragic um no
i mean you know those i don't even mean
anything big and bold
i don't i mean you know those things
that we want to say but we're not saying
them
um the things we want to try but we're
not trying them but
just just those little things that that
um
that are just right on the other side of
discontent and i think that we are all
afraid to admit that we have any
discontent or any longing
or that we can imagine anything better
for ourselves because then that might
mean that we have to do something about
it
yeah and so so in in a way we we long
for
sometimes the wrong things the the
temporary pacifiers the
the ephemeral pleasures the things that
don't make us better men and women that
are human beings
but uh that that distract us in the
moment
yeah and i think that's makes perfect
sense that we can be forgiven for that i
mean we live
in a in a capitalistic culture i mean
you know marketers jobs their whole job
is to sit in rooms and identify the
basic needs of human beings
and then attach products to them right
that's what they do that's their job
they do it all day
they're really good at it it's not
subtle it's literally their job right
so you know when people a woman said to
me
at a speaking event i put this in
untamed she said
i can't go around trusting my longing or
my desire i mean i long for a bottle of
malibu every night should i just
go for that and i said no you you don't
you don't go for that and you don't
trust that first of all i know you don't
trust that because you brought it up to
me
right right you know you know better
when you start asking a question like
that
the answer is often embedded in the
question itself
exactly exactly you already know and
second of all
when you when you have a surface desire
like the one you just like what you just
said
about you know the things that we think
we want
if you don't trust it then you just have
to look below it to the deeper desire so
what's beneath
that bottle of malibu what human
deep human need did those marketers
attach that to it's rest
it's escape right right what you really
want
your deeper desire the desire beneath
the desire is for some freaking
rest yeah and we have to ask the why
behind it right
because if we don't ask why then we we
go for that surface level thing whether
it's the
the bottle or it's the the rolex and i
know for me
you know throughout my my 20s which
feels like a lifetime ago now
i i you know i i wanted the the nice
thing
i really longed for them i thought i
longed for that but i was really longing
for what the the marketers and
advertisers were selling
underneath that the the sort of
acceptance of
others the the the love or
the uniqueness yeah and and
and i think that if we can get beyond
that you realize that of course the
rolex will
will never get you that but you can get
what you actually long
for yeah and no matter how many rolexes
you get
you will realize that it never works
because you can't ever get enough of
what you don't
need right so that's why
i mean i have a friend i put this in the
book i have a friend who
was obsessed joshua with getting this
beach house okay she wanted to rent a
beach house for the whole summer she did
not have the money for it
it was a very bad decision
and we kept talking about it trying to
get to the desire beneath the desire and
she burst into tears when
in the middle of our conversation she
said i just see all these people with
their families
at the beach and they look like they're
having they're connected and they're
having so much fun and i just feel so
disconnected from my family we don't
even talk anymore
by the time we got it to the end of the
conversation we figured out you know
what we should do
we should get a basket and everyone in
your family should put their phones
in the freaking basket before dinner and
you guys should sit together for an
hour and look at each other and talk to
each other
and she tried that and we laugh now
today because that
you know 15 cent basket was a lot
cheaper than a beach house
[Laughter]
yeah you can really buy a solution to to
your problems
it's true that money does solve money
problems but most of our problems once
our basic needs are met
tend not to be uh money problems at all
and in fact
we you know the house example is such a
great example i know that
that often when there are you know
failing relationships and
we what we try to do is like well i'll
buy my way out of this if we just had a
better house that would fix my
relationship if i just had the right
car or if i just had a kid with this
person i'm sure
that would fix the relationship and
of course all that does is complicate
things
that's right i mean joshua i convinced
myself that i would listen
i really should have had this talk a
couple years ago with you because
i convinced myself that i would be a
better writer if i finally had an office
okay because i um
write i started writing um when i lived
in such a tiny house that i
i wrote in the closet okay so i had i
wrote between like
piles of underwear and jeans and that's
where i wrote my books
and so i decided okay if i can write
books in a closet
imagine how good i would be if i had
like a real grown-up office right
so my wife and i moved i got a big
office
and do you know where i write where's
that in the closet
isn't that fascinating i wrote untamed
in a freaking closet because joshua i
can't sit i'm in the office now and it's
just too big and there's too many
distractions
and i couldn't do it and one day i
realized oh i gotta get back in the
closet
yeah it's funny you say that i i got so
used to writing at
all of our books at my kitchen table i
have a desk now that
um and i'll i'll work from there
occasionally but i still find myself
writing at the kitchen table because
that was the the habit i estab i
established many years ago as a place
that i feel the most creative at and
and you know you're right any of these
tools whether it's an office i mean
that can augment our experience
ultimately but it's not the thing that
does
the writing for us you can have the same
exact pencil as stephen king it doesn't
mean you're going to start writing
horror novels tomorrow
that's right that's right it's never the
thing
it's never the next thing it's never the
different thing
um no this is the the lesson i've just
and and by the way i still have to learn
it every day joshua like i
still can convince myself i have about
56
000 bottles of potions in my bathroom
and i can
i will still promise you joshua that
tomorrow i'll see something and be like
this is it though
this is the bottle of lotion that will
change my face and therefore change my
life like
the amount that i get suckered into this
stuff
um really is amazing to me marketing is
powerful man but you're right we all
just want
belonging we want belonging and we want
acceptance and we want love
and we think the rolex or the potion's
gonna get it for us and it just doesn't
i think that's a beautiful place to end
it glenn thank you so much i really
appreciate you
thank you i appreciate you and all of
your work you're making the world a
better place i really do appreciate it
all right the next quality conversation
that we had
was with our friend dave ramsey
so dave you probably know him as the guy
who's been given
financial advice for several decades now
ryan and i really subscribe to his way
of thinking especially with respect to
debt we don't believe
in having any debt in our personal lives
also in our business life we don't
believe
in having any debt and so i had this
quick conversation with him over the
phone i hope you enjoy it how many years
have you been telling people they need a
budget and now they're maybe
maybe starting to figure out within the
last month or so
[Laughter]
just a couple about about 30 i think
yeah
oh our brand has been validated and so
has yours right
oh my gosh you know so many people are
starting to ask like what is essential
in my life and it's like well i've been
trying to tell you for the last 12 years
yeah for real but you know maybe
sometimes it takes a
a sort of car crash of sorts either
literally
or or figuratively before we start to
question everything and now
i think people are finally starting to
question i've had so many people in our
own audience ask us
about this pandemic and now they're
starting to
to consider budgeting for the first time
as though uh
as they shouldn't have been before would
you say that your advice differs now
more than differs now than from what it
was two months ago
you know that's the wonderful thing
about what we've done for the same thing
for 30 years
it's stuff that works when times are
good and when times are bad
our advice is um essentially exactly the
same
we have always said you know giving you
the baby steps to work and be on a
written plan and stay out of debt and
save money for emergencies
we've always said that now in the midst
of this you wouldn't work
our baby steps plan if you are
in the middle of a crisis but if you had
called me two years ago and you're in
the middle of a crisis
i'm not telling you to work baby steps
plan and we're gonna get out of the
crisis first right
right and so you you stop paying extra
on your debt
you stop paying uh setting money aside
for
retirement for goodness sakes if you're
worried about eating and so you stop
everything and pile up cash and get
through the hurricane and then you go
back
after the storm blows by and and start
your
you know your more normalized financial
planning process again
you know a lot of people that we've
talked to about the every dollar app
is it they've found immense value in
that i mean it's
it's not appreciably different from
having your own envelope system you're
just doing it online you're syncing it
with
with your bank and and now people are
are beginning to realize like if i
actually
question the money that i'm bringing in
the money that's going out it's going to
be able to go a lot farther
well when better than in the middle of a
literal pandemic
that we want to be able to use our
resources deliberately right
oh exactly i mean what we've done here
at ramsey i've got a thousand team
members here and
from a leadership perspective in
business what we did immediately was in
order to preserve
those jobs and pay those people the
first thing we did was what conserve
cash and so we cut out any uh any
miscellaneous spending or delayed it and
said we're not doing that project this
month we're not doing that this month
we're not doing that this month
we're gonna stop everything because it's
more what's the most important thing
inside this building well right now it
would be preserve the jobs right
and keep everybody and keep keep
everybody without having to lay off or
furlough or anything
now when you're at home and you're
laying it out what are we going to do
we're going to lay out a written game
plan we're going to preserve cash
uh so why because we got to eat buy food
first and then we'll keep the lights on
and the water first second and then
we're going to pay the rent third and
uh we're going to worry about kids
college later
for goodness sake so we're going to
preserve and conserve cash
and nobody accidentally does that you do
that with a written plan and the written
plan
just kind of looks at you and says duh
here's what you should do
you know ryan and i often try to
differentiate between essential items
non-essential items and junk items
essential items are the things that
you're talking about we need to be able
to pay rent or our mortgage we
need to be able to have a a roof over
our head we need to be able to feed our
kids
we need to have the electricity on and
then of course we you know basic
clothing etc
we all have essential needs and then
there are non-essential
needs that are these are things that add
value to our lives and i think it's
incredibly important to have those
things
when we can afford them i think the
problem is
most of us mistake the essential and
non-essential things the things that add
value to our lives
with the junk in our lives we've been
marketed to to think that
that brand new lexus that costs 90 000
is going to bring me everlasting
happiness and and maybe in a time like
this
it's a time to not just say well what is
essential to me and and what adds value
to my life but
what kind of junk have i been spending
this money on why
why am i broke at this point it's
because a lot of the things i thought
were essential
actually aren't well that's exactly
right and
you know it is one of the good
byproducts of going through this much
societal stress this much
strain at home is you know
if it gets really ugly outside you
really start to
human beings are pretty smart about
what's essential and what's not
and and what's superfluous or junk and
uh
but when everything's going really good
it's it's more confusing it's more
blurry
to some people and they say things like
i
needed a new car
no you wanted a new car you didn't need
a new car
there's nothing wrong with getting a new
car if you want to and you've got the
money
but it was not a need and you really
don't get to say that if you call the
dave ramsey show i'll call your butt out
and go
it's not a need yeah i don't mind just
spending money on once
i spend money on once i got some nice
stuff but none of it is a need
i mean really there's food there's
shelter there's
utilities and basic transportation and
some basic clothing
and that's your need and most people got
that covered even
if if they're furloughed i mean they
really do because
it doesn't take a lot to cover that and
you go work a part-time job
delivering pizzas right now if you got
laid off and you can cover
the real needs it's not to say it's how
we want to live our life forever
but you know it just helps you get real
centered on what's real
what do you think this is going to do to
the housing market is this going to be
good news for some folks
i don't think it's going to affect it
substantially
except in areas where where folks are
out of work
for an extended period of time uh i mean
if
there's some hot spots around that may
not go back to work for quite a while
and if they don't go if that economy
that micro economy doesn't go back to
work it's going to affect that housing
market
but overall if uh your area
you're listening to this right now and
your area is back to work in a few weeks
um uh and you know there's who knows
whether that's true or not i don't know
i don't know what these characters are
gonna do but the faster we get back to
work the less it'll affect it
obviously but my supposition is is that
most of america will be back to work
quickly enough
that it will slow the housing market but
it will not tank the prices
you know one of the most controversial
things i'll often tell people is there's
no such thing as good debt and i know
you echo that sentiment
quite a bit or maybe that's me echoing
you but we're at a time right now
where people might be either
encouraged or at least they feel that
it's necessary to to take on debt
but can we can we talk about why that
might not be a good idea
even even in the time of a crisis well i
mean especially
in the time of a crisis you look up and
see uh i mean
the people that don't have any debt
right now and have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
have a completely different life
situation
than the people who are deeply in debt
and don't have any money yeah
and and they were the ones telling us
all along that that was okay that was
okay that was okay
uh the problem is it's a destabilizer it
adds risk to your life into your
business
uh and the more of it you have the more
destabilized you are
and here we are in a situation where the
wind starts blowing
and the big bad wolf is huffing and
puffing and sadly we're
watching people with you know the ones
that are in the straw house in the stick
house
is blown over and those that are in the
brick house with no debt and an
emergency fund are sitting pretty
and so i would want to be that little
pig that's in the brick house and uh
not be running to the very thing that
caused the problem for me in the first
place it's like
hey let's grab a hold of some concrete
blocks we're drowning
you know i think the the only reason not
the only reason but one of the main
reasons that
i'm i'm feeling calm throughout this
time of anxiety is because
i have a car but i don't have a car
payment i have a house but i don't have
a house payment i
i have essential payments like my
utilities and
and food but i don't have any any debt
and i have a
substantial emergency fund that i built
up over the last decade or so
and of course all of my my retirement
accounts are are funded but it wasn't
always that way with me when i was back
in the corporate world making really
really good money which there's nothing
wrong with that i spent even better
money and so
ostensibly i look like i had money but
man i i was
absolutely broke and i was working
really hard to buy things and
to maintain a lifestyle that wasn't
bringing me joy or happiness or
contentment and and i guess what i'm
looking
for from you here is what is the message
that you have of hope once we get out of
this for people because i know you and
your team
over there at ramsey solutions you've
been you've been working hard to
to make sure people understand that
there is hope on the other side
of of this crisis well there is
i'm old and i've seen you know 9 11
happen and the planes hit the towers
i i watched y2k happen before that
and both of these things were gonna ruin
our life as we knew it forever
in 2008 2007 hit and other miscellaneous
calamities have come and gone and
this too shall pass it's a really tough
time right now for a lot of folks and i
understand that and
certainly not shaming anybody not making
fun of anybody for not being ready
but i went through a really tough time
in the 80s when i lost everything in my
20s because i was stupid
and i had borrowed too much money and
there was a little snl
crisis and it caused the banking world
to change and i lost everything i owned
and went bankrupt and had to start
completely over with a brand new baby a
toddler and a marriage hanging on by a
threat
so i know when when you know when a
storm comes and you've been stupid and
it knocks everything over i know how
that feels
uh because i got a phd in dumb i know
exactly what it looks like so i'm not
shaming anybody
but this is wake up call for a lot of
people uh
like you said earlier that you know in
america we have
the best looking uh most well-funded
broke people on the planet
you know they're wearing stuff and
carrying stuff and driving stuff and
living in stuff
that they can't afford and they're
they're and they're
like a rat and a wheel just run run run
run run get nowhere
there's no sense of peace there's no
sense of contentment
there's no sense of spiritual
margin or emotional margin in their
lives
it's just everything is on a razor's
edge
and then when the wind blows you're
screwed
and and it blows all this stuff over and
it and then you just go
oh crud stuff is just stuff and you know
he with the most toys when he dies is
dead
you know the graveyard you just you
never saw a rider truck fall in a hearse
you ain't taking it with you baby
you know and so it's just you start to
you know when the wind blows like this
it helps you to get
a little bit more philosophical a little
bit more spiritual on how you're looking
at your life and that's a good thing
because that's what happened with you
joshua when you went through that years
ago
and the whole minimalist movement was
started and then you've guided other
people to do that
voluntarily and then i went broken
before that you know
years ago and obviously then i've guided
people to stay out of debt because of
that and i've stayed out of debt and
and to have money saved and when you got
a pile of money and you don't have any
debt
uh and this stuff happens again it
changes everything
when the wind blows i think we go broke
monetarily but but also that is almost
this this physical manifestation of
of this emotional brokenness and a
spiritual brokenness
they're all they're all sort of tied
together not standing in separate
corners of the room and
i think what we learn is when we
integrate our lives we start
aligning our values with our actions and
vice versa
that then that life is a much more
meaningful life
exactly and what does happen when you go
through those
metamorphosis times those times of
transformation is you have
a series of never again moments
never again am i going to be owned by
stuff and clutter you said i said never
again is a bank gonna call my
house and question my character if a
bank calls my house
joshua it's a wrong number you know
right i mean it's a misdial you know
never again do i want to talk to these
people never again
am i going to look at my wife and see
that level of fear in her eyes
because we can't keep food on the table
or lights and water turned on and i got
them turned off man
i'm babies i was that guy never again do
i want to be that guy
and so some folks in the midst of this
storm
it's a horrible thing you're going
through and i love you and i'm sorry and
i'll walk with you and i'll help you
but make this for goodness sakes make
this your never again
moment i love it i think it's a great
place to end it dave thank you so much
brother
thank you it's honored to be with you
guys all right today's final guest is a
previous podcast guest
sort of derek sivers one of the most
influential people
in my life sivirs.org is his website he
has a few books out right now
new books including how to live
which is his newest book but you can
find links to all of his books
on his website sivirs.org just one of my
favorite writers alive today
we had him on the podcast sort of in the
past we did a live event with him in
2017
in new zealand he was living in new
zealand at the time
and it was the first i think interview
he did in
something like three or four years does
that sound right sean something like
that
yeah and so we got him to come out and
do this live event with us you can go
back and listen to it uh the episode was
just called
sivirs we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well if you want to hear a
longer form conversation with him
but here's a short conversation i had
with him we covered
a bunch of topics over a short span of
time enjoy
derek thank you for joining me today
thank you for having me all the way
across the world
oh my gosh last time we were together
was in new zealand
and i guess that was what uh three three
and a half years ago something like that
yeah
and uh we both left and now i'm back
so i'm here in wellington new zealand
but yeah last time i saw you was in
auckland at a horse racing
course with your honestly i i i've done
several hundred tour stops and that
might have been the strangest venue
[Laughter]
the locals thought so yeah that was
awesome very unique
there were escalators and uh yeah i was
just waiting for a horse to bust through
a door at any moment
yeah anyway i figured we could start by
talking about beliefs
one of the things that i admire you for
is
when i look at you compared to your
average person
you seem to be less influenced by
mimetic or or societal beliefs
and you sort of have your own personal
beliefs how do you think you develop
this skill or what do you think that is
i think it's because i was
i think it's two things for one i was
just a long-haired musician
that wanted to be a rock star
and so i was surrounded by people that
were trying to
uh get into a good college and all of
that was moot to me
they were trying to get a good job
somewhere and that was moot to me
they were looking into like how to make
lots of money and
get insurance and health care and
all that was moot to me so for most of
it i just felt like i
the things that most of the world wanted
just didn't seem to apply to me any
anyway i was just pursuing a different
thing you know i was
i was the ringleader mc of a circus for
10 years from the age of 18 to 28 i was
in a circus
and so i guess that could be
a bit of a um alienating
thing where i just uh yeah most people
couldn't relate to the life of a circus
performer
full-time you know um i quit my last job
in 1992
i've been a full-time just musician and
whatever guy since 1992.
so i think that's most of it but even
going back further
um if you lay me on the shrink couch um
when i was five years old we moved from
chicago to or sorry we moved from
california to
england and uh i was
the american kid at an english school
and everybody uh
was really weird to me and seemed to
have different values for me and think
that different things were important so
i was just like yeah i'm not one of you
people and then we moved to
chicago and everybody called me the
english kid because i had picked up the
accent
and so once again i was just like i'm
not like you people
i you know i just felt that like ever
since i was like five years old it just
felt like
whatever situation i'm in it just feels
like the rules don't apply to me i'm
just
doing something else so um and i find
you i find your reaction to that
fascinating because a lot of people
feel that way i'm not like you people
but i might as well assimilate then
and and yours was sort of the opposite
of that where
it's uh it's almost pushing those
those societal or memetic beliefs away
and and making sure that what you're
doing is aligned with your own
we could call values we can call it
beliefs but with what you want to do
yeah and maybe it's flaunting it
for attention no i don't want attention
maybe i did long ago no i don't know
what was that thing yeah i don't know it
did just feel more like
you guys are doing a different thing
here you're you're
pursuing something that i'm not pursuing
so therefore all of these
norms and rules which seem to be about
fitting in
and being liked and all that stuff i
wasn't pursuing those in the first place
so um yeah i never wanted to fit in i
wanted to stand out i never wanted to be
normal i wanted to be different
and yeah i think that you have
mastered the art of letting go in many
ways for folks that are familiar with
your story
it's whether it's stuff or or places
or attachments you're really good at
moving on
and uh how do you determine when it's
time
to let go of a of a person place or
thing so that you can move on
wow that's a great question um i think
it's
personal development right it's it's
growth when you feel that
you've learned most of what there is to
learn here
then it's time to move on i love the
metaphor
that when you're playing a game like a
board game or something like that video
game board game whatever it may be
when you win the game it's time to stop
playing
and i think of that a lot too it's like
if if you set out to do something
and you've done it like say you set out
to make money
and you did it you made money well great
now you can stop playing that game it's
time to play a different game
but i think what a lot of people do is
they
they get into a game to go make money
for example
and then they achieve it and then they
keep playing that game
more and more and more to try to just
make some work whereas i
find it much more interesting in the
name of
growth to go learn a different game
let's stop playing the money game let's
play a different game and sometimes that
game
just amplifies instead of the
mercedes-benz it's the maserati or
whatever
the game is uh you obviously strike me
as a minimalist you certainly
are in many respects let me ask you this
how how has your relationship to
material possessions
changed over the years um
so i'm curious if you've found this with
all the people you've talked to on this
subject for the last few years
if there's a common thread i think most
of us
had to go through
it to get to the other side right like
when i was a self-promoting musician i
lived in a house full of
stuff i had a recording studio and this
is also back in the days when
uh to promote your stuff was more of a
physical thing i had
a thousand cds in boxes that
and a thousand padded mailers and i used
to have eight by ten
glossy photos which i would include in
my press kit with
cds and put into a padded mailer so my
house was filled with
promotional stuff and it was filled with
recording studio
stuff and i had two cats and i
you know i just i had a house full of
stuff but then i moved house like
three times in four years and each time
i'd pack
all that stuff into a u-haul
drive it somewhere and then unpack all
that stuff
and it wasn't until uh
my business cd baby was totally taking
off
was consuming every waking hour that i
moved into
a place uh that was actually my
grandma's
furnished apartment my grandma had a
little like guest apartment
next to her house that she let me stay
in
temporarily and it was just already
furnished so this time instead of
unpacking all my stuff i just put it all
into storage
temporarily while i stayed at grandma's
furnished
apartment and then five years went by
and i was still at the furnished
temporary apartment and all my stuff was
still in storage after five years and so
i was like you know
i guess if i haven't needed it in five
years i'm gonna need it
never so right i had 50 employees at the
time and i
just told my employees like all right
here's the the key to my storage space
everybody just go grab whatever you want
um one thing each please and yeah
somebody grabbed my base
somebody else took my piano somebody
else took my mixing deck somebody else
took my speakers and
and pretty soon i had nothing left but
my old paper diaries like my
notebook diaries i'd been carrying
around since i was 13 or something
and i looked at all these notebooks i
was like eh really am i gonna like
look at these things when i'm 50 nah
chuck it so i just threw him in the bin
and that was it i was left with nothing
but
a suitcase of clothes and um
yeah you know what i was thinking i was
thinking about you a couple days ago
because
i realized that it's my minimalism thing
is not just physical um no
dude i legally removed my middle name
because i wasn't using it
and that is that's a first for me
okay okay expand on this i i
hate having things i'm not using and i
just
realized like i've i never used my
middle name
in fact it wasn't even on my passport
because just years ago when they asked
my name i just said derek sivers and
left out my middle name which i had
never used since birth
and um then when i moved to singapore
and i became a legal resident they
needed to see my birth certificate so
suddenly like my singapore
bank account was using my middle name
and when i was trying to transfer money
from my regular bank account without my
middle name into my bank account with my
middle name there were delays because
they said the names didn't match
and it's like you know i don't use this
middle name
i'm getting rid of it so yeah it was
like 30 bucks and had to file a form
to legally remove my middle name but
there are a whole bunch of examples of
this like
if there's a there was a toaster
in my house that i wasn't using and i
hadn't used it in a couple months so i
gave it to a friend it's like just
anything i'm not using
i just don't want to have it uh even if
it's
non-physical um right but at the same
time
it doesn't seem to me that you deprive
yourself either and i think that's
an important distinction for people to
understand is that
you're not necessarily opposed to things
that are useful to you but if something
is not useful it seems as though it gets
in the way and you want it out of your
life you want to let go
yeah but even things that could be
useful
oh yeah i it has to pass a really high
bar i really don't like
letting anything into my life because
maybe i take things more seriously than
i used to now so it it feels like
anything i'm letting into my life like
it's like a like agreeing to adopt a
puppy yeah i treat almost everything
like a puppy
there we go good rule of thumb treat
everything like a puppy
ah yes well i like this uh ryan and i
call it the the justin case rule you
know there's so many things that we hold
on to just in case we might need it in
some
non-existent hypothetical future and of
course we never end up using those
things and so
giving ourselves permission to let go is
really freeing up space for the things
or the puppies that may actually add
value to our lives
speaking of letting go um i think we
have to let go before we can move on and
you've moved on a lot you've lived all
over the globe
you were just in oxford recently now
you're back in
new zealand i'd love to hear about why
that move
back but then i also like to hear about
your decision-making process how do you
decide when it's time
to move to a new place
um it's a
that's a tricky nuanced
answer that i can't give fully because
i have a kid
uh a mother that i we
have to compromise even though we want
very different things
out of life we have a kid together that
we're very 50 50 with
so um so decisions on where to live have
to be made together like if it were
just up to me alone i might be in
myanmar right now
and moving every three months uh because
that would be fun uh but she doesn't
want that so therefore we can't do that
we have to
find the compromise you know so um
that's my real answer with moving but i
think
kind of like your first question about
letting go
i think that about location too that a
place has something to teach you
and a place offers you
[Music]
a growth opportunity and when you feel
that you've learned most of what that
place has to offer and i draw the line
at most of because of course there's
always
every day more that you could learn from
the place but when you feel like
you've gotten most of what this place
has to offer then i feel
that it's actually the growth choice
to move on um
[Music]
i think a lot of my a lot of my thoughts
around this is influenced by
abraham maslow the
psychologist from a hundred something
years ago i think he was a contemporary
of freud's but while freud was studying
sick people abraham maslow went out to
study the healthiest people in the world
and find out what makes them tick and
he developed his theory of
self-actualization with this pyramid
showing your basic needs like food and
shelter
um at the bottom of the pyramid your
medium needs like feeling
heard and appreciated and doing good
work that you're proud of
and at the very tippy top of the pyramid
was the thing he called
self-actualization which was kind of
this
feeling that you're um you're doing your
unique contribution to the world
uh and his advice
after all these studies to people is he
had this great
uh motto that i've
been driven by ever since where he said
every day or he said 100 times a day
you're presented with the choice between
safety
and growth he might have said safety and
risk
uh and then he said make the growth
choice a hundred times a day
and so i read that as a teenager and
really took it to heart and i think
that's what i've been doing ever since
is always looking at the day-to-day
little choices between
safety and growth and choosing the
growth choice
do you find that returning to a place
opens up
a different world view or do you see it
through a different lens
you've you've returned now to to new
zealand
i assume there's other places you've
returned to in the past singapore
perhaps but
um do you find you come back after being
away
for a while with a new point of view
hmm yes and no
um i guess like watching a movie
a second time years later you do see it
through new eyes but come on let's admit
it for the most part
you've seen that movie like yes you
might get a little more out of it but
you it would be a better growth choice
to just watch a new movie
you know um so
yeah i guess i feel that about places
too i'd rather just
go for a new place that i'd never been
to instead of back to the same place
again
but you know we all know sorry to
interrupt
so we it's just not only as people do we
have different values you know some
people are just
way more into family for example or
we're way more into
uh hedonism that they may just kind of
follow the sun follow the weather go
where their party is
so we all have different values but i
think what 2020
showed a lot of us is that our values
can change
based on the situation you know so
in 2019 your top value might have been
travel you would have said travel's the
most important thing to me and then
suddenly 2020 happens and you go
huh oh um maybe not dying is my most
important value now
i think i've just changed my values
based on the situation you know
whether we having a kid can change your
values uh
sure getting fired from a job can change
your values
uh winning the lottery changes your
values you know we have to admit that
our values uh we have some values that
are there just
by nature some that are there because we
just grew up being told that things
these things are important and sometimes
our values are very situational
and as soon as our situation changes our
values change
yeah i like to think that we have
different types of values like
foundational values
or are things that are probably not
going to change for us and by the way i
think they're pretty similar for most of
us whether it's
health or relationships and we we can
you know define those differently and i
think they're they're different for each
person but then you have
these sort of surface values yeah like
travel for example that might be
a value for you but for me it may be
less of a value and then
i think many of us have the imaginary
values the sort of societal values the
things that have been thrust upon us and
we think they're important but they may
actually be getting in the way
of us living the life that that we want
to live
i appreciate your honesty around the the
uh question around
moving back to a place well i feel weird
sometimes when people
say like hey well why'd you move to new
zealand and like
it's complicated you know oh yeah yeah
and by the way that's
evolved right right and sometimes that's
the only honest answer is it's
complicated right there
i i don't have the the sexy answer for
you
um how uh to pivot a bit what
you're on social media you're on twitter
we actually before we pivot to this
stuff
uh i've just recently about a month ago
met somebody uh that we just kind of
just random like stranger uh kind of
thing and
we were comparing notes and suddenly
we're like shocked at how many things we
have in common like
really weird esoteric things like you
know even when you said
in this interview you say you know you
seem to move on more than most people or
whatever
so i met somebody else that also had
these really weird approach to life
things in common also very nomadic very
like ever changing
and it wasn't till a few days of
conversation that i found out that
he also um is not
into his family like his parents like i
also feel
like i've always felt very disconnected
from my parents like even as a little
kid i was just never into
family bonds and when we found out that
he was the same way we're like
whoa i wonder if this is a common thread
like
if you don't feel very connected with
your family
then all these other
traits maybe fall into place like being
nomadic
constantly looking for change instead of
security like maybe there's some kind of
um
because we didn't have warm and fuzzy
positive feelings around security
in the family home front maybe that
leads to other things so it's
interesting like
you know i'm 51 now so even at the age
of 51
still finding out maybe
why i'm this way you know i don't
question it that much so
every now and then it's weird to get a
new insight into why we are the way we
are
yeah and it's interesting going back
sort of tracing the dominoes back to the
the first one that fell
and you know it it's almost it seems to
be difficult to be able to even talk
about something like that
uh for a lot of people because there is
a societal expectation
it almost seems callous but i i think
it's i think it's the opposite
personally i i think to be able to have
honest honest conversations about things
like that is actually a compassionate
way
to to talk about you know the people who
raised us or the people
uh that that were around you know 24
hours a day for a long period of time
yeah i do want to pivot over to social
media because i
uh this uh i don't know there's been a
whole lot of talk there's a new
documentary out there now with that's
called the social dilemma and a lot of
people are
are finally waking up to the idea that
hey maybe these things aren't as
nebulous as as we initially thought i
mean they are
tools but there are also thousands of
well-paid engineers
who are working very hard to aggregate
your eyeballs onto these tools
and i want to i just wanted to figure
out how your
views about social media have changed
over the last
decade or so um
they haven't because i've never been
into it i've never used it i've never
even found it at all appealing
but i just recently had a little insight
into why
uh some others might you know you and i
are both a little bit famous already
and so we already have a percentage of
our life that is public
um not like you know paparazzi at the
door public but you know just the things
like this interview that we're putting
out into the world that a bunch of
strangers are gonna hear
and most people don't have that at all
um yeah and so
[Music]
their outlet to
share things in the public is just
through
social media through posting things on
their platform of choice
and somebody asked me recently
uh if having a kid
makes you give up your public
aspirations give up your
public uh life and i was like no i said
i
i need a balance um i think a life that
was a hundred percent
private doing nothing in the public or
for the public would be really sad for
me
but on the other hand a life that was a
hundred percent public with no private
life that would also be really sad to me
yeah so i think i always need the blend
you strike me you strike me as a more
more private person
um although you certainly have this this
public facing piece of you whether it's
your your podcast or or your books or or
your website you know with the articles
that you write there is a public
facing derek sivers derrick no middle
name
sivirs and yet
you i there is not a piece of you and i
admire this about you that
it doesn't seem to me that you attention
is not the point of
doing what you do no but if that's what
i mean about the zero percent right like
if i had none then maybe i would be
doing things to seek
attention you know like i've already got
enough attention for my balance
so i'm not seeking any more i don't
really post anything on
social media why would i wha what would
be the point more attention i don't want
more attention
ah but it's because i already have some
so then i realized like okay when i see
just random you know girl from
ohio or um kazakhstan or
peru or whatever is posting uh
a picture of herself on instagram today
i think why would she do that then i got
ah because this is
she's reaching for her own balance that
makes her happy of doing
some things publicly and
yes she is seeking more attention than
she has right now because
she doesn't have enough and at some
point she might reach the balance where
that's enough attention for her
and then of course you know we see
famous narcissists
that no amount is enough for them they
just want
it all and there's no amount that could
ever be enough
um but we all just find our own balance
so yeah i suddenly had more compassion
for the people that are posting selfies
online that i never really
understood that before i thought about
this uh public private balance
and and you found you're enough and i
think that's
the key here is determining what that
enough is being honest with yourself
about that
in fact i think most of us never
ask what is enough right we're always
either accumulating more more and more
and more more
or even even when we're letting go it's
like well how much is enough
letting go because do i need to become
an aesthetic
do i need to become a spartan in some
way or
is there enough letting go or is there
enough accumulation
and and what does that mean i think
quite often we don't even know why we're
doing what we're doing it's just
there's some hypothetical happiness
that's just around the bin that of
course
we don't arrive at if we don't determine
what is enough
although it's not bad to seek it i mean
if you use the physical metaphor of your
walking into a dark room you need to
kind of stick your hands out and feel
where the end is where the boundaries
you need to hit the boundaries before
you know uh where you are
so like we said earlier about having too
much stuff
most of us will have to go through the
process no matter how much they may
listen
to to you and what you've put out in the
world they'll have to hit their limit
themselves of having too much stuff and
feeling the pain from that
right before they finally said okay now
i know where my
enough is and you know lucky me that i
won the lottery in a way of selling my
company at the right time
where i was able to feel um that enough
with money too and just feel like okay
no this is enough for me like i'm not
playing that game anymore i'm not
pursuing money anymore because
now i know i've reached the amount that
that was enough but if i hadn't hit that
i'd still be pursuing it
right yeah i uh with the minimalists we
we don't do we're not allergic to money
uh
but at the same time we we
uh try not to let it be the primary
driver it's allowed to be in the vehicle
but not
behind the wheel so so to speak uh and
we
often begin our our podcast with uh with
this little phrase uh this episode of
the minimalist is brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
and um i i i've heard you speak on this
in the past and my guess is that
probably resonates with to
with you yeah to some extent because i
don't want to
i i hate listen i start hate starting a
podcast and hearing eight minutes of ads
or hearing
interrupted by ads um and
i think ads are dangerous to a certain
extent but i also think there may be
times where they're potentially
beneficial can you speak about
both sides of that or either side of
that ah yeah
um okay so tim ferriss is a friend of
mine i've known him since
um 2007 or so
and he's gotten a lot more famous since
then
and um so it's been funny to like as his
podcast especially took off
and i think that's been his despite the
success of his books i think his podcast
has the biggest audience of anything
he's ever done
so yeah he's got like eight minutes of
ads up front and
i was giving him hell for this like dude
come on it's you know i know you
i know you don't need the money why are
you doing this what's with the eight
minutes of ads
and he just said you know i i wish
um i wish this weren't true but he said
those ads bring in so much money and he
said
i've given them to i give the money to
this cambodian school project that's
like
created so many schools and put so many
kids through school so
when i make this decision of like
should i get rid of all the ads i think
yeah i could get rid of the ads and then
4 000 kids in cambodia won't be going to
school anymore so he said
you know it's not ideal but it's net
positive those numbers is exact words
but that's that was kind of like the
the gist of the decision um is
yeah um i recently
put out my first book in nine years my
first new book in nine years
and i sold it only through my own
website
and i thought i was gonna sell maybe
thirty thousand dollars maybe forty
thousand dollars
were the books and in the first month it
sold over a quarter million dollars like
in the first three weeks
and i'll admit i was elated i was
walking on air i was like whoa a quarter
million
bucks in a few weeks from like for my
book and i think it just felt really
sweet because that was the first time i
had charged money for anything in a long
time
and like so many people opened up their
wallets
and bought that book directly from me it
was like
it was super touching it was really
really
like soul nourishing sweet it felt a
hundred percent
amazing i was so happy
and then a few weeks went by
and i thought okay well uh what am i
going to do with the money
i don't i guess i'll put it in a
vanguard account or something put it in
index funds yeah i guess that's what i
should do
i guess i should stick that money into
index funds because
you know there's nothing i want to buy
so that's the proper thing to do with
extra money
and i thought god that's just there's
something kind of sad about it like i
was really excited to earn this money
but i was not excited to keep it and
it was actually a conversation with a
friend a screenwriter a lithuanian
screenwriter friend of mine who lives in
germany
that i said hey like what do you do to
celebrate like i never celebrate
like that's just a thing i've never done
and
she's the one that said um she goes well
someday when i sell my first
uh tv screenplay she said there's a
forest
in lithuania that i want to buy to help
protect
that forest from development i was like
oh
and she was yeah that to me would be
celebrating my first wow
tv screenplay i was like ah charity as
celebration that's brilliant like whoa
and then of course it just like i
couldn't
unthink that idea and within an hour i
was
like i know what i need to do with that
quarter million dollars
and so i went to givewell.org which uh
i had been aware of for years they're
just these data nerds
that were interested in what is the most
rationally effective form of charitable
giving
meaning yeah the how much money will
save the most lives
um best bang per buck of her lives saved
and then they crunch the data
and they find out of all the charities
in the world which ones
are saving the most lives per dollar and
of those
which ones would save even more lives if
they had more money like they are only
money constrained therefore if you have
some money to give
all all things being equal this is the
most rational choices to give
to these charities and they basically
list their top three
and so i picked the top one which was
the against malaria foundation
and i entered an amount into the
calculator which said that if i
donate uh 250 000 to the against malaria
foundation that it saves
i think it was like 139 lives i was like
well
there we go all right
no contest so immediately donated it to
the against malaria foundation and saved
139 likes 139 people won't die
because i charged 15 bucks for my book
and yeah that felt really good because i
was almost about to give it away
so coming back full circle to
having advertisements yeah i hate ads i
do everything on my computer to
block ads at every step so i never see
ads online
and uh i'm fully against ads but then
oh no i'll admit when tim ferriss
explained his point of view on it i
thought
all right i get it that's an interesting
nuance yeah for sure by the way i should
probably mention the the book you're
talking about is your music and people
um
also hell yeah or no those are your new
books okay both books
um by the way your books are probably
the only books i buy by the case and
just hand them out to people
thank you that's what that's a big part
of why i went self-published you know i
had a
my last book was on penguin portfolio
and
the my main contact there is a real
sweetheart who's a fan
has always told me like hey whatever you
do next we want it it's an
instant yes to your next book in advance
and i just decided to
go self-published because i like to be
able to
uh give someone like you a create of
books
wholesale instead of you needing to go
buy a hundred from amazon and
give jeff bezos all that money um i'd
rather just sell at wholesale so um
yeah i even got to play with pricing
like i decided to make the paper book
just four dollars which is about it's
like it costs about like three dollars
something to print
each book so i just sell the paper books
for four bucks because
i don't need to profit off of the paper
you know
so it's kind of fun to like when you're
self-publishing you get to make your own
rules for pricing and things like that
too that's right
well that's rather considerate of you
which is uh just really a segue for
my last question for you here you've got
this um
point of view this idea of something
that is
meta inconsiderate now so maybe you
could expand on that but by
well you can maybe talk about what it is
but then also can you give three
examples of something
that is perceived by our society to be
quote
considerate but it may actually be
meta inconsiderate
yeah um so the big idea
is that there are things that we
we think of as being considerate and
maybe on a base level it is
but in the bigger picture it's maybe
doing more
harm than good so um
say giving let's first we'll start with
the uh
theme that comes up here a lot which is
stuff and gifts
so giving someone a gift saying oh well
it's their birthday let me go down to
the store
and buy my friend a thing because it's
their birthday
um yeah on one level on a shallow level
that's considerate
but i would think that's kind of meta
inconsiderate
because now you're giving your friend
a thing that they have to take care of
or dispose of
and then feel the need to reciprocate
and do that in the future because that
you did it for them and it
just kind of sets a bad precedent so
that's to me like a
shallow considerate but meta
inconsiderate um
in interpersonal relations i think of it
often in
terms of uh romantic things when you
meet somebody that you're head over
heels for and you
drown them in compliments you may think
you're being considerate
by telling somebody all these sweet
things
but in a way you're being kind of meta
inconsiderate because
um people like
the the joy of the chase they want to
aspire
to be with somebody they want to feel
that they're uh
that they need to win your heart not
that
uh the second they said hello they
already had your heart that's a little
sad
so you've denied them the joy of of
chasing you if you uh are just all over
somebody that you
you like um so that's kind of where i
first started noticing this idea as a
friend of mine
in singapore was just head over heels
for another friend
of mine it was just like gushing all
over her and just
beating her over the head with his love
i was like dude
i know you think you're being
considerate but you're you're being rude
you're being over the top
meta-inconsiderate um
so uh it would be more meta-considerate
to
let her come to her own conclusion and
um
not put her up on a pedestal um as far
as a
third um
i might even say with
social media stuff um like
the amount that you put out into the
world um
people may say they want more more more
from you but actually
they like wanting more
wanting is a nice feeling um yeah so
maybe it's better to just uh sometimes
let them
want a little more and then give them
more i
i think of me um and the ex of mine like
20 years ago
my uh my girlfriend at the time uh
she she would do this little thing about
like what are you getting for my
birthday tell me tell me tell me i said
no
i'm not telling you she goes oh please
please please tell me what you're
getting me for my birthday i said no no
i'm not telling you
and she's oh please please please please
tell me i said okay you really want to
know yeah i really want to know i said
all right a necklace and a trip to
mexico and she went huh
you weren't supposed to tell me
[Laughter]
and i said i know don't worry i didn't
actually get you a necklace on a trip to
mexico
i just knew that you didn't actually
want to know
she's like okay so it's like yeah she
liked
yearning to know she didn't actually
want to know so um
right maybe with the amount of stuff
that we put out into social media and
share with the world
it's better to have people uh want more
from us
i like to think you know writing wise
you know when i whatever i put out
in the world writing wise is usually
very succinct
and i have this my rule of thumb is uh
if they wish i would have said a little
bit more
then i've said just enough um
man i think that's a great place to end
it actually
[Laughter]
derek sivers thank you so much brother i
really appreciate you i love
talking with you anytime so thanks for
having me on
all right there are 47 more of those
quarantine slash quality
conversations over at theminimalists.com
support also as i mentioned this week
ryan and i we're gonna go
in depth on the minimalist private
podcast
we're gonna talk about the last 10 years
some of our achievements some of our
biggest failures
some of the lessons we've learned but i
wanted to sum it up
with uh this essay that i wrote if i
were to
sum up the last 10 years the lessons
that i've learned
in in one essay it's a recent essay that
i wrote over at the minimalists.com
it's called what is clutter our clutter
isn't relegated only to our material
things we clutter our lives with
destructive relationships careers
obligations rituals busyness
minutia news media politics
gossip drama rumors we clutter our
attention with glowing screens
we clutter our creativity with
distractions
we clutter our free time with
trivialities we clutter our desires
with attachments our lives are brimming
with existential clutter
emotional clutter mental clutter
spiritual clutter
so much so that it's hard to distinguish
what is clutter and what
is not we are stressed out overwhelmed
and anxious because we filled our lives
with disorder
chaos though there is a solution look at
an object
a commitment a habit does it bring
tranquility or increase your well-being
if not let it go
not an easy fix but a simple one
now i think when ryan and i first
started this journey
and sean can attest to this he's been
here for the vast majority of it
when ryan and i first started this
journey it did start because we were
overwhelmed with stuff and our material
possessions are a physical manifestation
of what's going on inside us
and so by letting go of those external
things
i was able to over the last decade
really deal with a lot of this other
clutter
as i said in the essay our clutter is
not relegated only to our material
things i think it starts with the stuff
that's the initial bite at the apple
but that changes everything else you're
able to look inward
and deal with the busyness deal with the
minutiae deal with the
media clutter deal with the glowing
screens to a great extent
and so minimalism can apply way beyond
the stuff i want you to keep that in
mind because you'll often start with the
stuff or you'll struggle with the stuff
but when we're done struggling with the
stuff the struggle doesn't end
it opens up a world of possibilities for
decluttering
decluttering our life of all of these
complexities to make room
for what's truly important all right
before we get into our listener tips and
our added value
segment today let me encourage you to
become a private podcast supporter you
know this podcast is 100
advertisement free that's because of
this small group of
five or six thousand people who decide
to support the minimalist
podcast and because of that actually
two-thirds of our podcast
is on the minimalist private podcast
it's really a space for ryan and i can
let our hair down we can talk about
things
in private or semi-public with an
understanding group of people who allow
us to
fail and screw up out loud in real time
it's a different experience from our
public podcast but it's a much deeper
experience as well maybe it doesn't
reach the same broad audience
that this podcast reaches but it goes a
lot deeper into
the things beyond the clutter and the
deeper conversations we also have
with our guests this week ryan and i are
really going to go deep
into our 10-year history and even a bit
before that as well
if you want to check all that out we
encourage you to just try it out for a
week or a month it's cheaper than a cup
of coffee you can head on over to
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app by the way if
you become a supporter you also get the
entire back catalog
we're talking hundreds of hours of past
private
podcast episodes we think you'll enjoy
those of course you can walk away at any
time if you
feel like it's not adding value to your
life let's see we got some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners as
well
check them out hello from the uk i was
recently listening to the podcast on a
minimalist christmas from the 1st of
december
and i wanted to share with you some of
the things that we do with regards to
gift giving
and my family absolutely love to give
gifts to show their love and
appreciation
and i usually make a homemade gift for
some of our family members
which is appreciated so much more than i
ever anticipated that it would be
we do either baked goods homemade
decorations
and wreaths made from foraged foliage
so it's a really fun thing to do with
the family in the lead up to christmas
to make all of these gifts
ready to give to them on christmas day
and
i think that they just appreciate it so
much more than
a bought gift because it is so heartfelt
and the time and effort that's gone into
it so hopefully that helps somebody
and have a nice christmas hi
this is shelly lipman and i'm from
windsor connecticut
i had a thought regarding shredding
there's a lot of people who don't want
to purchase
a shredder but all of a sudden they'll
be cleaning out and they have a lot of
shredding to do
so here's a couple of ideas the first
one is to call your local banks
a lot of them will offer free shred days
and
you don't have to belong to that bank to
take advantage of that
if you don't want to hold on to the
shredding until a bank has a free
tread day the other option is to call
places like easter seals who work with
people with disabilities a lot of them
will have shredding operations
and for a pretty reasonable fee will
shred all of your
stuff and the money goes back to easter
seals and it
offers um you know employment for people
who have disabilities
all right y'all for our added value
segment this week
well it's the end of the year right it's
our 10-year anniversary it's also the
end of 2020 what a year it has been but
there's been a highlight of the year for
me and it's been music every year i
think this is my 10th year doing this
now
or close to that i put together a like a
top 10 list sometimes there's 12 songs
some or sometimes there's 12 albums
sometimes there's seven but it's my top
10 albums of
the year or top however many albums of
the year and 2020
has been a surprisingly great year for
music
there have been some that really
surprised me i think there are some
folks that
are releasing music that otherwise
wouldn't have released music and i think
we're
of course my my taste is if you're a
long time listener of the podcast you
know my taste is fairly eclectic
everywhere from singer songwriter to
atmospheric music
to 90s rap music like there's
there's not a whole lot that connects it
all it's a beautiful collage of
sound in fact if there's anything that
connects at all it's just i
really enjoy music i like having a
soundtrack to my life
and so if you head on over to
theminimalists.com
sound that's where i put all
every list so this this year's 2020 list
but you can find the past year's list as
well the
the top 10 albums of 2020 the
minimalists.com
slash sound all right real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
really exciting that's going on in the
life of the minimalists in just a few
weeks on january 1st
our new documentary it's called less is
now
will be on netflix you can check out the
trailer
on our youtube channel we'll have a link
to it there actually you know what
let's just put a link to it in the show
notes we should have the
trailer out by the time this episode
comes out you can check it out
less is now it's a an expansion a deep
expansion
into minimalism we went out we talked to
a bunch of everyday minimalists people
who were profoundly affected by our
first film
we also went out and went deeper with
some experts we had folks like dave
ramsey or tk coleman
but also annie leonard and danae
barahona and
and several other people who really
helped us dive deep into these different
areas of relationships and the
environment
and dealing with spiritual clutter
internal clutter uh the economy as well
you know
we we they're obviously economic
implications
with respect to minimalism we address
all of this in a relatively short film
it's less than an
hour long it was really important to us
to make this as short as possible
i was really hoping to get really close
to 40 minutes we didn't get
to 40 but hundreds of hours of footage
that ended in less than an hour that
really is
what minimalism or simplifying is about
right it's about
about removing that excess and getting
really down
getting down to the essence what is
truly important a lot of stuff hit the
cutting room floor a lot of really great
stuff
but the ultimate finished
film is i think you're going to find out
to be really meaningful i know i
certainly have and
i couldn't be happier with it the first
time in
we were going through this in so many
iterations and eventually
i feel like oh wow we've made something
that can stand up to our first film one
of the most difficult things to do
is say wow how can we how can we beat
that well we didn't try to beat that
what we tried to do
is live up to the same standards but
then also improve upon it expand upon
this vision of minimalism so less is now
we'll hit netflix
on january 1st new year's day 2021. you
can check that out
all right you can follow the minimalists
on facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo
to podcasts at theminimalists.com you
can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist if you
want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists.com you'll also
receive our simple sunday emails
whenever we send those
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it